in japan a princess niece of the emperor
was married this week a union that's
been highly controversial long postponed
and which led to her exit from the
imperial family from tokyo here's lucy
kraft
shortly after her marriage to a commoner
and the loss of her royal status the
former princess macko faced millions on
live tv flanked by her new husband kay
kamoro a man some here consider unworthy
a financial dispute involving the
groom's mother turned the royal romance
into tabloid dirt and even sparked small
public protests
still suffering from post-traumatic
stress disorder triggered by the public
bashing maco and her husband spoke for
just a few minutes the controversy and
the pandemic had forced the couple to
wait four years to marry but it comes
with a lot of sacrifices portland state
university japanese studies director ken
ruoff called the royal melodrama bizarre
there is a lot of angst among japanese
about the pandemic
about growing economic inequality
about the fact that the economy has been
largely stagnant about the rise of china
and very sadly they're turning this
anger tragically against this against
this young couple from their demure
attire to their modestly folded hands to
their frenetic schedule of diplomatic
and charitable events the royals are
tightly micromanaged making this week's
dramatic exit all the more shocking
while they've been compared to britain's
harry and meghan who also broke with
royal life the japanese princess and her
new husband a recent law school graduate
aren't expected to seek the limelight
more likely what is going to happen is
she's going to disappear she's not going
to be on oprah
i'd be amazed
reports say the couple will move to new
york as early as next month
for this princess a fairy tale ending
means leaving the palace seven thousand
miles behind
for cbs news saturday morning lucy kraft
tokyo